Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
We are continuing on with our complete guide
to Teleport course today.
Before we begin, I will caveat this with
this is my first stream on my M1
Mac. As such, if anything seems weird, please
let me know.
I think my audio is okay. I think
my video is okay. I think my scenes
are okay.
But feel free to jump into the chat
and say, hey, something's not right, and I
will do my best to fix it
because
we want this to sound and look as
good as possible.
Alright. So what is on the agenda for
today? Well, today, we are diving into
another workshop where we take a look at
running Teleport on top of Kubernetes.
There's
some weird things
to discover when working through this,
just that Helm charts are a little bit
difficult to find.
Some of them are deprecated, but it's not
obvious that they're deprecated.
And I'm gonna try and do my best
to just kinda walk you through this from
each step.
If we pop open my screen share,
we
have the new workshop pushed to the Rawkode
Academy
slash courses repository on github.com.
You will find a directory called eight kubernetes
with the README that we will be using
for today's session. So feel free to work
through this
and let me know how you get on.
Today's is a little bit different from the
other ones I've done. Normally, I try and
hide the answers. Today, I have to say
we just kind of leave them all here,
more of a follow along.
Let me know which format you prefer and
we'll tweak that for any future workshops.
The prerequisites
for today are obviously Kubernetes,
easiest thing in the world to deploy.
Everything we're doing today should
should work
on local
Kubernetes setups, but you will have to bear
in mind that
Teleport
really wants to be served over TLS.
So, really it wants a domain name,
and you may find you have to do
a few extra steps to get this to
work with Minikube or Kine or any other
Rancher desktop, Docker desktop, etcetera. So, for today
and to make my life a little bit
easier,
I am using
managed Kubernetes clusters. I have two on Cboe
and one on JKE.
And I'll explain why I've made the decision
with these two clusters, the three clusters,
as we work through the exercises for today's
workshop.
Okay.
So
we got we got people here.
Hello, Moz.
Hello, Russell.
Thank you for joining us.
If you missed the caveat at the start,
let me know if my audio was okay.
I'm on a new machine and I'm very
worried because the audio is always the first
thing to break.
Okay. So the first thing you have to
do when you want to deploy
Teleport to Kubernetes is just to say what
way you want to do it. Now, the
Teleport team do provide some Helm charts that
allow us to simplify this process.
So we're gonna run through those today.
For me, the first thing I had to
do was find the Helm charts.
What I would suggest is go into the
Teleport Teleport repository.
They're not gravitational.
Got that wrong already. Here we go.
They're not in the most obvious place. Typically,
projects in the cloud native space will have
just a deploy or a chart directory at
the top level. I mean, it's almost ubiquitous
now across most
Go projects at least.
However,
Teleports live under the examples repository.
And that seems to be their examples of
how to deploy Teleport rather than like their,
this is our production deployment, you can go
and just use it as you wish. It
feels like it's take it, maybe modify it,
and make it suit your own needs.
But we are gonna use them today. So
an example of ratio, we have chart,
and we have a whole bunch of things
here. Now,
most of these charts are deprecated,
but there's not really any way to know
that without looking into the actual chart dot
YAML,
where it will say
deprecated true
here.
So while there are a selection of charts
here,
only two of them are presently
doing anything.
I popped that out. We don't need
to.
So I've kind of broken it down in
this readme of what these charts are for.
So we have the Teleport cluster chart,
and that's just sets up your standard single
node Teleport cluster running on Kubernetes with a
local authentication back end
as opposed to OAuth, GitHub, SAML, etcetera,
using a persistent volume claim for storage.
And really
it's the easiest way, right? You can just
deploy this chart,
update some DNS records, which we're about to
do, and you get a working Teleport cluster.
Now you do have to go onto the
cluster itself and manage your users, etcetera.
But these are examples. So you can take
that config map. You can swap out the
local authentication and you can configure it with
your GitHub application credentials if you're using open
source. If you're using enterprise, hook that up
to Google SAML, whatever you want, and go
nuts.
It seems to be that the Teleport chart,
which was essentially the exact same as the
Teleport cluster one, is deprecated. I assume this
was just the first one that they started
putting together and then decided to kind of
deprecate in favor of the Teleport cluster. So
we won't be looking at Teleport. If it's
deprecated,
please don't be using that as an example.
The next thing I found, and I actually
got quite excited by this one, the Teleport
daemon set. I was like, yay.
We can
run super privileged pods across all of our
infrastructure and get us to switch access to
them well, so I'll get an access to
a Kubernetes cluster at the same time. This
is also deprecated. However, I am going to
be replicating it through my own dirty hack
today. So you can't use the redeemer set
chart, but it was good as an inspiration
for just a proof of concept that I
wanted to build out together.
Welcome to it up. Nice to see you.
Okay.
Let's keep working. So we've got the Teleport
Kube agent. We are definitely using this one
today. This allows you to if you have
an existing Teleport cluster, possibly the best way
to run Teleport is on bare metal and
then expose all of your cloud stuff back
to it. However,
and the KubeAgent chart is the best way
to get started with that because you can
just deploy
the Kubernetes proxy with that configuration to any
Kubernetes cluster and then filter them all back
to some other Teleport, and we will be
looking at how to do that today as
well.
The next chart is also deprecated in the
last chart, which is the Teleport Auto Trusted
Cluster.
This seems to be a chart which, again,
is good as an example if you want
to go and see how to implement this
stuff.
But Teleport works really well in a cluster
of cluster mode, in that you have one
centralised,
pet like, super friendly cluster that you take
care of, and then you have other Teleport
clusters
at the edge or on different regions, etcetera,
which can then use
the root cluster for authentication,
privileges, permissions, etcetera.
We
may actually do an episode on the kind
of federated cluster of clusters approach towards the
end of this course. So, tuned for that.
I actually need to update this. You should
not run a daemon set when it was
deprecated. This is what I was going to
try and encourage, but we're going look at
doing this a different way.
Alright. So, exercise one. We know where the
Helm charts are. We know which ones are
active, we know which ones are deprecated, and
we have a good understanding, hopefully, of what
each of these Helm charts does.
Now, the next step is we want to
install Teleport to
one of our Kubernetes clusters.
So, I've included
let me zoom in a bit. There we
go.
Can we go one more? Yeah. There we
go. So, I've included a bit of a
warning at the start of this task.
The Teleport charts are not published through the
Artifact Hub.
If you're not familiar with the Artifact Hub,
there
we go, Artifact Hub. This is like the
new Helm Hub
or even a replacement or discovery mechanism from
the Google Helm stable and Helm incubator,
etcetera, where you can just come on and
fax it for something that's definitely not gonna
be there.
Like the reddest chart, and you can see
that this is by the Falco team. We
got one by Bitnami, the Bitnami chart is
usually a pretty safe bet for everybody.
But if you search for Teleport,
there are charts here
and
they're all
not official.
They're contributed by other people, other teams, etcetera.
So they are there. You may find them
that way, but I would probably suggest that
you use the ones provided by Teleport.
And in order to do so, you can
just do a Helm repository or Ripple add
Teleport with the URL.
I've already done this. I don't need to
do it again, but I can run Helm
Ripple list, and you'll see that we have
already added the Teleport repository to my local
environment.
You can also,
if you want,
just do like a shallow clone of the
actual gravitational Teleport repository.
When you're deploying and using Helm,
if you don't want to include
the chart name or repository slash chart name
at the end, you can just use a
local directory,
especially if you do want to make modifications
to the example charts and to replace that
local authentication with a GitHub authentication, etcetera.
So, that's a really good way to do
it. We probably won't do that today unless
I'm getting particularly bold
towards the end. We are just gonna use
the example charts with a little bit of
configuration.
Cool. So, we're just going to copy this
verbatim and
deploy our first Teleport cluster using the Teleport
cluster chart
to my first Kubernetes cluster.
I am using
Kubei.
Trying to at least.
How'd you do it? Oh, there we go.
I've got my three different clusters here. So,
I'm going to deploy to JKE first, and
then I'll tell you why I'm deploying to
JKE first.
We'll make sure that I have JKE
cluster. So, I'm looking for
Yeah.
Some of this stuff only really exists in
a JKE cluster.
Plus,
what do we need? Oh, yeah. We're copying
and pasting this command.
Nope. I've now copied and pasted the wrong
thing.
Much better.
So, we're going to call this helm release
Teleport cluster.
It doesn't really matter what name you give
it.
You just need to be able to know
the name when you want to run helm
upgrade commands,
to be able to tweak or modify the
configuration.
We're going to run with Acme on. So,
one of the cool things about Teleport, and
we covered this in the first installation video
where we looked at running with Docker and
with the
compelled binaries,
is that it has built in support to
reach out to Let's Encrypt to get certificates.
So in order to enable that, we just
need to set Acme to true
and then pass in our email address because
less encrypt requires that all
certificates have an email address with it so
they know who's provisioning them, there are wait
limits, etcetera.
And we give our cluster a name. This
is going to be a fully qualified domain
name. And for today, I am just using
my Rawkode.sh
domain, which is
relatively unused to date.
I'm telling this chart to create a namespace
and that I want to keep all my
Teleport stuff in a Teleport cluster namespace,
followed by the chart name.
With this, we can hit return.
Wait just a moment.
And it is deployed.
So we can do Teleport
cluster
get
pods. We'll see that's currently container creating, so
we'll stick a watch on that and just
give that a moment. So this shouldn't take
too long.
It's just provisioning a persistent volume,
pulling image and starting the container.
We can see that it's running now and
it's healthy.
So,
we're kind of almost
done.
Of course, I'm gonna show you it working.
You don't need to take my word for
this. But the reason we're using the JKE
cluster first is because
one of the things that the chart does
by default
I
really should just set my namespace, we'll do
it this way. One of the things the
chart does
by default is deploy a load balancer type
service. This is a Kubernetes service where the
type is not cluster IP,
it has load balancer. So, this does not
work in all Kubernetes environments and the fact
is very unlikely to work in Minikube, Docker
for Mac kind
because they won't have the ability to provision
a load balancer.
The service type load balancer is really a
cloud construct with providers for AWS,
GCP,
DigitalOcean, Linode. They all have cluster controller managers
that monitor for this service and actually reach
out,
get an Elastic IP,
and then attach it to the service.
So, I use JKE so you can see
that work.
And the next step I need to do
is to copy
this IP address,
jump over to my DNS,
and add a record for the fully qualified
domain name that I added to my cluster
and save that.
And we just need to give that a
minute for that to propagate.
And what should happen?
Is we should be able
that's my cloud instance, Teleport.Rawkode.sh.
And we should be able to browse to
this momentarily.
There we go. Awesome.
That's one of the reasons I use Cloudflare.
The propagation of their two ENSE records is
just ridiculously fast.
And we have Carlos with us today. Hey,
man. How's it going? Nice to see you.
Okay.
So we have deployed with the Helm chart,
Teleport cluster to JKE. It's got our load
balancer. We updated our DNS record.
Teleport can now satisfy the ACMI challenge,
and we have a cluster.
And we could tick our box in, yes,
we've created our DNS record and it worked.
However,
you may be running a local environment or
non cloud environments, bare metal environments, where there's
no load balancer service, and I wanna run
you through how this works too.
Well, I do provide another command here,
and we will switch my
Kubernetes context
to Teleport one. This is
a Siebel KCS cluster.
And
it responds.
And it does. Awesome.
So, I mean, we could do the same
helmets document I just run. However, what we're
gonna see would be the service
Comment from Russell saying my audio is a
bit muffled. Maybe I am just muffled. I'm
not sure. I'll try and then see a
little bit better.
But thanks for the heads up.
Okay, so we could deploy the We could
run the first command again to this cluster.
However, the service load balancer would set in
a pending state indefinitely.
Civo Cloud,
along with many other clouds, just don't provide
load balancers as a service. They're also expensive.
If you run a Elastic Load Balancer on
AWS, I think each one of them is
20 to $25 a month.
You can go down the road of using
the application load balancers, which are a lot
cheaper.
Carlos thinks I'm getting sick.
Maybe I am.
If it's just that my voice sounds a
bit nasally, perhaps I am getting a cold.
I mean, I have a three year old
who's been at nursery for
just over, well just under three months and
she's pretty much been home with new snot
and sniffles and coughs every week. So, I
guess it's inevitable that I'm going to catch
something.
Okay.
Alright.
Stay track.
So,
yes.
ELBs are expensive.
ELBs are cheaper and require more setup, but
you can just not use a service of
table advancer at all, which is what I'm
gonna show you guys. So,
we'll paste in this command
and you'll see that it's this Talm install
Teleport cluster. So it's the exact same ACME
true. We're still passing in my email address.
I am gonna change the name on this
just so I can have multiple DNS records,
and we'll call this
civo1.
Rockcode. Sh.
And now I'm using the helm.
Thanks, Carlos.
And now we're passing in a set service
dot type equals cluster IP. So now we're
telling this Helm chart, don't deploy a load
balancer, use cluster IP. I work out how
to get traffic to this in my cluster.
And here, I decided
don't know why I decided to try and
do this with the local chart, but I'm
gonna just change that and stick to what's
worked so far,
which is Teleport
cluster.
So almost identically the same command, only we
are overriding the service type.
This will deploy to Cboe
and we'll look at how to expose this.
So
we've got the same namespace,
But we can just keep that watch on.
I
don't like it when I see pending.
was very,
very worried there that I had deployed my
SIBO cluster without a CSI.
I wasn't even sure if that was a
thing,
but we're okay. So, the pending was provisioned
in persistent volume and the claim.
Container creating now means it's pulling the image,
and hopefully very quickly, we're going to see
that this is running. And I can panic
a little bit less.
Guess we just wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait.
So, as I say here,
you will need to create some sort of
ingress resource. So,
this Civo cluster
does get one public IP address,
which is load balanced
by default.
Because it's a workshop,
So Carlos is saying,
why am I using Helm directly and not
doing getups?
I would love to be doing getups,
but, you know, this I I just wanted
to be able to run through the commands
in an interactive fashion, like as if you
were building a proof of concept, and then
the getups can come later when you know
that it works.
However, a great question.
Say that again. Yes.
So, the Civo cluster comes with one IP
address with a load balancer.
It deploys with traffic by default as ingress.
I'm a fan of emissaries, so I just
swapped out.
What that means is,
and we can see that our Teleport is
happy, which is good.
If we do get svc dash all,
we
have
our
ambassador,
which is Emissary NGRIS,
as a load balancer, which gets that one
public IP address that is available.
That can route all other traffic via the
NGRIS or mapping objects as Emissary calls them
to the service inside of the cluster.
You can see we actually have our cluster
IP service here for Teleport.
So, in order to make all of this
work,
we need to first create the DNS record
for
C4-one,
I believe I called it.
Point it to the load balancer and hit
save,
and then create an emissary mapping. Now this
could be, if you're using traffic, use whatever
traffic custom resource they have. If you're using
Kong or you're using NGINX Ingress, whatever you're
using, you can just go to that.
You may even just be using networking V1
Ingress.
That's fine too.
So, I'm going to create my mapping.
YAML.
My host name is SQL one.
No prefix.
And I believe the service is called Teleport
cluster. I'll quickly double check that. Yeah. Teleport
cluster, Teleport cluster.
And I can now hopefully
just apply this to the same namespace.
I call it mapping.
Alright. We're debugging.
So what happened there is
my cluster is telling me that kind mapping
doesn't exist,
which I was not expecting.
So, we can use API resources.
And I wanna see
what we get in the ambassador namespace.
Ah,
this version of ambassador
is old
Because nothing ever goes simply. Alright. Let's upgrade
it. I mean, could just do like a
map in v2.
But I I don't know what's the best
approach.
I'm gonna I'm gonna upgrade it. So we
got ambassador here.
Edit
deployment
ambassador.
And we can see
We have ambassador Edge Stack one thirteen ten.
Updating that seems like really risky, doesn't it?
Maybe
I should just use the old mapping.
Drop the version there. Oh, wow. It's really
old.
The problem is when I was using the
Civo create cluster, they have like a marketplace,
which clearly they don't update their applications because
this is,
there's a substantial difference here.
However, I can still go to these versions
of the docs, which means
can hopefully
Yeah, this looks almost the exact same. So
I'm just going to
We're just gonna hope for the best
get ambassador.
I'll be two.
In fact, that leads to alpha.
Maybe this is better.
And
Teleport cluster
apply
dash f mapping.
Alright.
Port cluster.
I didn't know that was a thing on
Twitch, Russell.
Russell suggests that if this was on Twitch,
we could bet channel points. I'm not sure
what channel points are or whether I break
my cluster.
Maybe next time.
Okay.
Let's see
my services
and my mapping.
This this this may work. I have I
you know what? I have no idea. Let's
find out. Civo one
Rawkode SH.
Well, first challenge.
The certificate is the ambassador Edge Stack self
signed one,
which means that Teleport hasn't been able to
satisfy
its
Carlos is asking, why didn't I use traffic
from Civo?
I could've.
I just I like emissary ingress from the
times I've used it. I don't think it
would be too much of a hassle to
swap it out.
I am very much regretting
that decision.
But let's just see what happens.
So
we're having emissary. So the DNS record is
going to my ingress controller, which is correct.
However, the certificate that we're getting back is
incorrect.
So we can do a cboe rockode
dot sh
and reset dash
dash b
cboe one.
Alright. And then if we want to debug
the certificate,
I think we can add.
I
can't remember.
Capital a.
So
I'm gonna try one thing before I move
on to the next step. I mean, all
I was gonna show you is that you
don't need a load balancer. I've kinda proven
that, but I haven't got TLS working, so
it's not ideal.
But
close enough. Right?
I'm gonna look at the logs to see
why our ACME challenge hasn't kicked in.
Right. So management search is in ACME.
Let's try just restarting that.
When in doubt, a reboot fixes everything.
Well, let's delete our pod. We'll force stack
the challenge to come through. Now that the
DNS is there, we'll see what happens. Feeling
that and moving on. It's not a big
deal.
Okay. Follow log.
Patience is a virtue.
I've landed on another node and it's still
an image, isn't it? There we go.
Okay.
Must be quite a big image.
Bonus though, because this is my first stream
using the m one, it's also the first
stream that when I'm not talking,
there's actual silence in there. Like, I cannot
hear the fans from the machine. In fact,
they're not even on.
Wow. Slow.
There we go.
Okay.
Logs.
So our TLS server is x two. Is
that old or new though? Oh, it must
be current.
It's the M1 Pro top of the line,
not the Max, but the best Pro option.
I couldn't justify the Max, Russell.
But I could have, but I would have
been bullshit to be honest.
Oh, well. Alright. So
here's some advice. Obviously, try things before the
stream. The second,
now that I think about it, the fact
that we've been done the Emissary route, which
also has support for Let's Encrypt, I should
probably disable the ACME support
and Teleport and let Emissary deal with it
and that would just fix this. I think
what's happening right now is that Teleport is
trying to answer the request, but it's not
really getting to it.
So, we're just gonna skip this stage and
say, voila, it'll work.
Use whatever ingress controller you've got to maybe
handle the TLS certificate instead of Teleport's ACME.
I will
play with this another day and get it
working and do a small fifteen minute tutorial.
Awesome.
Okay. What's next?
It's annoying though.
Of course.
Her heart is the Emissary TLS.
That feels like a rabbit hole. I don't
really need to go down.
Yeah. Doesn't matter. Doesn't matter.
All know what cert manager is.
We all know how ingress things work. I
don't need to fix this right now. Okay.
So let's
close this one and close this one and
pop back over here.
So, the important thing was just you don't
need to have the load balancer,
but just the cluster IP and then handle
the ingress to your cluster, however you handle
it already. I mean, you're already gonna have
services
that are getting less encrypted certificates somehow and
getting routed via ingress somehow.
So, just use whatever you know
and maybe
I'll do the same next time.
So, the next challenge was,
if I to pop open
Teleport. So this is my JKE one,
which I never created to use before.
Let's do that quickly so that we can
take a look at something.
So let's go back to our JKE cluster.
Get pods.
I'm gonna actually just exec into this for
a moment and create the
our first user. So we can do TTL
users add roles
access,
editor,
order,
login,
route,
and the username, of course. Login.
And then accept my own invitation.
We can close this. We see getting started.
Save the password.
Test Teleport
Rawkode.
We'll copy the password.
Yeah. I just have I how is that
gonna
does it really scan that already for me?
That would be impressive. Normally, I have to
do that manually. Let's see.
No. Yeah. I don't know where that came
from. Let's scan it properly.
Let me use this one.
Okay. So,
that first Teleport install that we did, you
see that there's no server access.
There's no applications of course, but we do
have access to the Kubernetes cluster. So, I
could
run through
these commands to do that.
But we probably, depending on your Kubernetes setup,
is that you probably still want that server
access or at least the ability to SSH
onto your node, your nodes within your node
pools, node groups, etcetera,
for any sort
of debugging or
manual commands, of course, that you want to
run.
Of course, we want to be in a
world where we never need to be able
to do that, but we're not quite there
yet.
And
Teleport did at one point support the daemon
set chart,
which of course is gonna run some extremely
privileged pods inside of your cluster to expose
that host through Teleport.
I couldn't get the daemon set chart to
work. And plus, I didn't really like what
the daemon set chart was doing.
Now, understand why it was doing it, but
it was just dreadful. It was actually running
a privileged pod,
installing Teleport onto the nodes, configuring a systemd
service, and then starting the systemd service.
At which point, the daemon set chart itself
becomes completely irrelevant. So, it was just like
a really hacky way to get Teleport running.
So, I decided, well, let's just try and
do this as Kubernetes as we can by
using a daemon set that just runs the
SSH proxy
and see how far we can get. So
we are doing things like hostpads and I'll
talk about some of those annoying hacks, but
for the most part it kind of works.
So,
the first thing we need to do,
and I haven't done this on the JKE
one, so I'm gonna get myself into trouble
now, but we don't have a working Cboe
cluster. So, what can I do?
You'll see there is a lovely warning here.
Teleport
definitely do not endorse this approach,
but it's
a good experiment, right, to see how things
work.
So, the first thing we need to do
is modify the config map that the Teleport
cluster chart deployed.
The reason why is that we need to
be able to provide some static authentication
so that when we deploy our daemon set,
is that it can speak to the Teleport
control plane.
The way that we do that is just
by adding a token. So
let's do it out of our container,
Teleport
cluster,
get pods,
and get config maps.
So our
Helm chart deployed
the Teleport
cluster
config map.
We can go down to the off service
here.
You can see the domain name. You can
see the authentication is type local.
We're gonna add tokens.
Now you can add tokens for a variety
of purposes in Teleport.
You you could add coop tokens, you could
add an app token, you could add a
DB token, depending on what you want to
expose.
We want to expose nodes. So this is
a token
that anyone,
anyone with that token
can join your Teleport cluster as a node,
which means exposing server access.
You can set the string to anything you
want. I am going to go with random.
And I'll just quote this because I have
no idea if that space would be included.
I actually think it would be.
And I'm not even sure that this is
all this is
this isn't a re this is one string.
I'm just I'm yeah. I'm gonna do this.
So, now this is a node token with
the string random, not space random.
And because this is Kubernetes,
that means that the pod,
even though it is mounting this config map,
has no idea that really it's changed, and
I don't think Teleport is monitoring it
using I'm notifier or anything like that. So
we're going to delete the pod
to force Teleport to detect that change and
restart its server.
Okay.
So, if we run get pods, we are
running, not quite healthy, but we are running.
So, we can move on to the next
step.
So, I talk about deleting the pod here.
You can use a label selector if you
want.
We're going to deploy a new config map.
So, this is to provide a Teleport config
where the off service is disabled, the proxy
service is disabled, but we do enable the
SSH service.
We're just adding some labels so that we
know this is a Kubernetes worker node, and
then we configure it to speak back to
our auth server, which is on Teleport.Rawkode.sh,
with the auth token that we created.
And then we have a daemon set,
which is host PID,
host IPC,
and host network. So we want this pod
to feel like it's the host
from the Teleport Connect SSH. We're
not I'm not doing anything with a fail
system.
If you really need to be able to
do that, of course you can go ahead
and do that.
But really I just wanted to do some
simple process exploration to see what's running on
the machine and look at stats,
CPU utilization, etcetera.
So, you can extend this further. Maybe I'll
update that with some more hacky mount stuff.
For these kind of privileged pods,
what we would do is mount the entire
host file system onto slash host. You could
definitely do that here and then you could
share route if you needed to. Of course,
I don't think you should have to be
able to do that. That doesn't work to
what I'm doing, but still.
Let's copy this
and we'll call this ds. Yaml,
Drop this in.
Where's my token?
And this is normal YAML, so the space
doesn't matter. And I actually think I've done
this in a way that I don't need
to modify anything.
We can now
apply
dash f
d s.
If we run get pods,
this is just a one node JKE cluster
because I'm cheap.
But you can see that we now have
our pod running. Now we can take a
look at the logs. What we expect to
see is that it is attempting
to speak to our Teleport cluster, and the
join token should be accepted.
There
are no logs because I've just realised
I'm telling it to go to a file.
No big deal.
If we hit refresh on this page, I'm
hoping,
there we go,
that this now shows up. So, we've now
enabled server access
with
DaemonSet running in an extremely privileged fashion.
Carlos asking a question.
That's the minimum, host pad needed.
So,
you can actually run this daemon set without
host pad, without host IPC,
without host networking,
and it will still work. But you're gonna
get server access to the pod.
I'm just trying to make that slightly more
useful for its intended purpose, which is host
access.
Going so far, it's just not to mount
the host file system.
What that means is if I click root
here,
I can see everything that's running on this
machine.
Like I said, you could easily mount it
to our host file system to slash host,
But it's just not needed. We can run
top, we can see what's going on in
this machine.
Really, I'm just exposing enough that I feel
I can debug something that's wrong with this
machine.
In fact, with the permissions I have now,
I could from here mount the host file
system.
We have complete access to the blocked devices.
So, you can do anything you want.
I think that would work.
Dev SD
one.
Yeah. There we go.
But we don't wanna do that.
So, there's no
let me recap. There's no supported way from
Teleport yet to really run-in this configuration.
The idea,
I'm going to speak for Teleport, what I
think they're going for here. They're a very
security conscious company.
I don't think they would encourage running privileged
pods in this fashion.
You'd probably, as you configure your nodes, would
run the Teleport agent from there and keep
it out of the Kubernetes system altogether, only
running the kube proxy inside of the cluster.
I think that's the ideal way.
You can do it this way though. I've
ran this as an example. Use it as
you wish.
Okay.
Yeah, Mollis, you're 100% right. The security people
would just not be happy with running the
pods with these privileges.
Really,
as an example,
you can do it
and only you will know what you need
to expose from server access at this level.
So just give yourself enough to be able
to get SREs or ops people to do
the jobs. They probably have SSH access to
the servers anyway,
but I don't run SSH in production. So
I would probably give them best route because
it's just all
audited.
Although I'd probably run Teleport through node provisioning
rather than Kubernetes with a daemon set. But,
you know, we don't always get to pick
and choose.
And Carlos, yeah, got it. It's just so
that when you SSH in, you have visibility
to other bits here. That's the only reason
I gave it up, is so you can
run it like debugging that 101, right? It's
to run PS and see what's going on
with the system and then probably followed by
talk to see what's using resources.
So, I just wanted to enable that use
case and that was all.
Okay, so we're gonna take a look at
our last step now,
which is we
have this other
Kubernetes
cluster
Pop down here.
Oh, I need to be in the same
folder because that's where I stored
my context. So this shell is now going
to be Teleport three,
which is another SQL cluster.
We still have our JKE one on the
top.
There we go.
So, can we run the other Helm chart
that Teleport does support, the KubeAgent one, to
give access to this cluster from anyone authenticated
against this cluster.
So,
the first thing we need to do is
create a token. So this is very similar
to the static one that we just created,
only this is the slightly nicer way of
doing it.
I can do this from
t c t
no. Because I'm not authenticated. I'm
not authenticated against this cluster on the command
with TSH login.
Although I could be, right?
Yeah. Okay. Let's do it.
TSH login proxy,
and this is
not my Teleport Cloud.
User
Rawkode.
So, there I can get CLI access to
this Teleport cluster. Provided
I have
this,
my password
and my OTP,
which is the bottom one.
Okay.
So now we should be able to do
TSHQLS,
certify cluster.
We should be able to do server,
SSHLS.
Something wrong with that tunnel.
I'm just forgetting how Teleport works.
Yeah. SSH is actually SSH.
How do you list the servers again?
Nodes LS. Okay. So TCTL.
There we go. So, I now have command
line access to my JKE
Teleport,
which is where we wanna be.
I'm gonna create this token,
which is the type cube. So remember when
we added one to the actual configuration file
in the config map, we added a static
token. This is a dynamic token, which will
expire in forty eight hours.
And it's basically one.
There we go.
So we can now
use this token for the next two thousand
eight hundred and eighty minutes to register a
Kubernetes cluster with this cluster.
Got it.
Let's copy the fact. Let's get the command
first. So this is the Helm
chart that we're using now.
So, we're sending it to I'm getting myself
confused. That means you must be confused as
well, but I'll I'm gonna slow down.
So, on our Civo cluster, we want to
deploy a new Helm chart called Teleport Kube
Agent. We're gonna create a namespace that's gonna
be called Teleport.
This time we're setting the roles to be
Kubernetes.
This deployment
is only going to expose
our be a Kube proxy.
We could also do DB
and app. So, if there were databases and
applications that we wanted to expose, we could
do them in this fashion. But right now,
we're just focused on Kube.
Our proxy address is not gonna be my
Teleport cloud account. It's gonna be our JKE
cluster. So, we're gonna use teleport.rockwood.sh
on port four forty three.
We then need to provide our auth token,
which we have access to here. We just
created this.
Delete the dot.
And we give this cluster a name, which
is CVo3,
and then we're specifically deploying the Teleport KubeAgent
chart.
Cool.
Alright.
So, now we can take a look at
the Teleport namespace. We can see the pod
is pulling. We're gonna have to wait for
that image one more time on a fresh
cluster, unfortunately.
But if we wait ten to twenty seconds,
what we are going to see is that
this proxy registers with our primary cluster, which
is available here.
And in fact, it's already there. There we
go.
So now,
even though I'm authenticated against my Teleport JKE,
I can use that to query any other
Kubernetes cluster within my infrastructure.
I don't even think that was running yet,
but it is.
So, we can pop over here.
And what I'm gonna do is, you know,
if I run kubi,
kubi
ctx.
You know, I do have access to all
all these clusters just because of the directory
that I'm in. I'm gonna go to the
temp directory.
And if I run kubi ctx,
we don't have anything. We have no access
because we're not in the right directory anymore.
In fact, I don't think I can even
run.
Although that may still be configured for the
JKE one.
But that's okay. It's the JKE one. We're
gonna try and preview the other one.
Maybe I should just unset all of this.
Was that too bold? Where? What?
Where are those two times coming from?
Okay. That should definitely feel alright. Yeah.
Okay.
So now we have access to no Kubernetes
cluster.
So we're gonna click connect on this.
We don't need to log in. We've already
logged on to our Teleport cluster.
We do a TSH kube login to c
v three.
And
kubectl
get
notes.
This worked last time.
Yeah, Russell. It was. It was my QConfig
was pointing to that local file,
which is why I was so confused because
I had dropped out my QBContext.
Qb is a command I just discovered today.
Really cool though.
Okay.
Ten minutes to debug. Why that authentication failed?
Do we wanna try that or no?
During my tests,
this just worked. Right? So
when you do a TSH kube login,
what that does
is
pull down some Kubernetes.
Okay. Let's do config view.
Yeah.
When
you do the TSH kube login, it configures
you a kube config.
It sets up the certificates,
points it to the cross
points it to the cluster.
And then you've got some
exec helpers where it's using TSH just to
validate your config and stuff like that, your
your credentials.
And then normally when I do get
pods, it works. However, this is telling me
that the user cannot request Kubernetes access,
has no assigned groups or users.
Now what that means
is
what this means is that my user here
doesn't have permissions
to
be part of that Kubernetes cluster.
So I could come in and take a
look at the rules here.
And we can see,
and that should be okay. I actually don't
have access to the Kubernetes cluster.
This must be a Teleport bug.
Alright, I'm gonna try and fix it.
I will reach out to the Teleport team
and see what happens. However,
what's important from this final
update the access rule for Kubernetes.
Yeah, nice one, Miles.
Carlos
saying Rawkode is missing. Moz is just telling
me to go
all smashing on it and give myself everything.
So, this is filling at the Teleport level,
not the Kubernetes level. In fact, we
can prove that. We can
connect to my GKE cluster.
Run get pods here.
No. We wanna speak to the
We wanna speak to the SIBO where the
the proxy is.
I'm only gonna spend a minute
on this.
So let's export.
Where's my SQL three?
Teleport three.
Teleport
get pods.
Log slash s.
There we go.
So,
this is showing us, this is the Kubernetes
proxy on CvO3,
which is actually telling us that a client
connected. So this is, this was my request
coming through.
If we do
Is that gonna do it? No.
I guess because I already had the session.
It'll only log in and log out.
It looks like I am
speaking to the proxy and that's going okay,
but then Teleport itself is saying that I
don't have the permissions to do what I
wanna do
when we run get pods.
This user cannot request Kubernetes access. So my
Teleport permissions don't really allow me to do
what I wanna do, and it's telling me
that because it has no assigned groups or
users.
I haven't modified this before.
If we modify the access one here
maybe Moz is right.
Maybe we could do this, which would get
me root in a cluster.
So on a Kubernetes cluster, this is my
JKE one. We can run Kubernetes get
cluster
roles.
And there's admin.
It's not system master though, is it?
Grap.
Yeah.
System.
I guess I could just do admin.
Basic user may be healthy.
Let's try admin.
My service accounts.
I feel like I'm going a bit rogue
here.
Grap system.
I don't know what service account we'd wanna
try and be.
Let's just try the group. I'm gonna save
that.
Now the next thing I need to do
is
TSH
log out.
Log in because you need to log out
and log back in to refresh your permissions.
And this is going to be TeleportRawkode.s
h user Rawkode.
I need port.
Password
and
token.
Kube
login.
We got a little bit further there. So
now I'm getting user Rawkode cannot less resources
pods in API group.
So
that
horrible little hack half worked. Like, I now
have convinced
Teleport that I have access to this cluster.
We're now querying
the Kubernetes API.
However, have now broken the authentication and let
things in the user Rawkode
rather than something else. Now,
I mean, I could just go down the
road here of creating a service account called
Rawkode and giving it whatever cluster pending I
want, but I'm not gonna do that because
I am out of time and I'm just
going down a really horrible path of showing
people things that we shouldn't be doing. So
what I'm gonna do is I'll reach out
to Teleport, I'll work out why this doesn't
work out of the box, but it has
previously with Teleport seven. So I think this
is a change in Teleport eight and we'll
try and get that bug report logged and
resolved.
Phew.
That's quite a lot for one hour.
So, yeah, a few comments. Carlos is asking,
am I impersonate in the service account being
used by Teleport?
Kind of. Your Teleport user is getting mapped
to a service account with some rule bindings
in the cluster. You get to configure all
of that.
By default,
it just can't work. I'm not really sure
what's happened there.
Russell is asking, if I only have to
log out if you add new rules and
not change prefs.
You're right. I didn't have to log out.
Good catch. In fact, is right there behind
you. No need to log out.
Okay.
As Carlos says,
thank you.
On how to hack yourself. Yeah, there was
some terrible advice in today's workshop with regards
to
running
privileged daemon sets and modifying permissions forever.
Yeah, Moj, I could create
a service code called Rawkode and give it
cluster admin in the cluster. But
that shouldn't be the approach of what people
take home from this workshop. So,
will log the bug. We will get it
fixed. We'll do every follow-up in a week
or two whenever it's ready.
But thank you for joining me. Had a
lot of fun running through this. It's on
GitHub. Feel free to do it yourself. If
you have any issues
then you can just open them on the
repository and I'll do my best to get
them fixed.
Nice little laughter there.
Yeah. Carlos is saying, don't forget to join
the Kubernetes happy hour this week.
Carlos and I are hosting the Kubernetes office
hours tomorrow.
That is at two p. M. GMT.
So, come and join us for that. And
Russell, you're not getting admin. Although maybe I
will federate some Teleport access. It'd be a
bit of fun one day.
Alright. I'm logging off for today. Thanks for
joining me. Have a good one, and I'll
see you all soon. Bye.